mais que faisait du nitrate d'ammonium
en plein coeur de beyrouth
depuis sept ans ce sont en effet près de
3000 tonnes de ce composant à risque qui
étaient stockés dans un entrepôt
vétustes du port de la capitale
libanaise
pourquoi pour qui ce mercredi certaines
sources de sécurité clair la situation
tout commence en 2013 lorsqu'un bateau
moldave venant de georgie fait escale à
beyrouth en route pour le mozambique
avec à son bord de 1750 tonnes du fameux
composants chimiques face à une plainte
d'une entreprise locale le bateau est
arraisonné et la cargaison stockés dans
un entrepôt dédié aux marchandises
confisquées une marchandise
placé sous la garde d'un représentant de
la justice et dont la direction du port
n'a pas le droit de disposer
malgré tout la situation ne bouge pas
jusqu'au mois de juin 2019
face à des plaintes répétées contre des
odeurs nauséabondes émanant de
l'entrepôt la sûreté d'état du liban
lance une enquête sur cette cargaison
elle signale alors le stockage de
matières dangereuses qu'il est
nécessaire de déplacer
l'autorité est également alarmés par les
fissures lézardent dans la façade du
hangar nous avons alerté la justice à
six reprises entre 2014 et jusqu'à
récemment sur la nécessité de réexporter
cette marchandise hors du pays
mais la justice ne nous a pas écoutés il
ne s'agit pas d'une question relevant
des douanes
car cette marchandise était stocké dans
un hangar du port de beyrouth
ces hangars sont dirigés exploité par la
direction du port
et cette direction est sous la tutelle
du ministère des travaux
face à l'urgence la direction du port on
voit finalement des ouvriers réparer les
failles de l'entrepôt des travaux qui
selon les sources de sécurité serait
bien à l'origine de la catastrophe
mais pour certains cette affaire résume
bien la complexité politique du liban
selon le journaliste ryad kobeissy les
services des douanes cherche à se
décharger de toute responsabilité
cette affaire met en lumière l'état de
délabrement et la corruption au sein des
douanes
qu'ils assument en premier lieu mais pas
exclusivement la responsabilité du drame
en attendant deux enquêtes l'une
judiciaire et l'autre sécuritaires ont
été ouvertes
le gouvernement qui s'est réuni en
conseil des ministres au palais
présidentiel de baabda a de son côté
décrété l'état d'urgence pour deux
semaines à beyrouth
le gouvernement a également décidé de
donner à l'armée
la possibilité de placer en résidence
surveillée toutes les personnes
soupçonnées d'avoir joué un rôle dans ce
terrible accident